hey guys justine and today we're
checking out one of the brand new
cameras by DJI this is the Osmo pocket
and this thing is so tiny and is so
awesome I cannot wait to unbox it
spoiler alert I actually already opened
it up to look at it because I couldn't
wait to film the video I try to package
it up very nicely to make it look like I
didn't open it just keep that in mind
you may be familiar with DJI they have
the Osmo Mobile's which you can put your
phones in there also famous for their
steady camera line which are the Ronin
and the new roller desks which I also
reviewed previously on my channel and I
love the road and I just shot a really
fun video with it and while I absolutely
love the Ronin and the shots that you
can get with it it's heavy it's big it's
not something that is compact like this
so I am super excited to check this out
this is also 4k you can shoot at 60
frames a second it connects directly to
your phone this camera looks very
similar to what is on one of the Mavic
drones it's one of the things that I
think is so important about filmmaking
or just taking photos or anything in
general is if there is something that is
small and compact that you can always
have with you that's what's most
important I can't lug around my ronin at
all times but this is something that I
actually could keep in my pocket great
name guys great names alright let's open
this up I'm gonna use one of my new
knives that I got the brand is James
they're based out of Portland I believe
comes with this cute little cloth even
come in this nice little wooden box
alright James are you ready for your
first cut also something that's cool is
on the box it says right here this is so
cool it says first cut this will be my
first cut awesome a mobile bow like
I sliced through the box actually I
didn't just take a peek in here so I
didn't completely ruin it this is the
little case and here is the camera
itself it's crazy because it's really
small but it has a significant way to it
like it's not heavy but it just feels
substantial so it doesn't feel like
you're not holding anything that's
probably because of the battery so with
a one-hour charge you can reach a 90
percent battery level you can shoot for
two hours on 4k and 140 minutes if
you're shooting in 1080p
there's also have some intelligent
features which we're very used to with
DJI products like active track face
track panorama time lapse motion lapse
HDR photos also has an LCD there's a
micro SD card slot you've got some
buttons to record and select there's a
little adapter that you can put here
depending upon what type of phone you
have so if you have a USBC micro USB or
a lightning that is inside of here so I
should probably open this up so that was
probably the thing that I need it it was
so the slides in just like so they even
thought of everything you're gonna keep
your adapter on that's nice so another
thing that's interesting is this now
uses an all new app it's called DJI MIMO
so let's turn this on the Westie card hi
oh my gosh this is so small basically
the drone camera but on a gimbal this is
also touchscreen a lot of things that I
can do on here so I'm gonna plug this
into my phone this is crazy
it just it just turned on it just works
now that we've unboxed let's take it out
and test it out oh this is gonna be so
fun you should probably get an SD card
today we're off on adventure we're in
Big Bear and right now you may see
behind me we have a Ford Raptor for the
week now we're taking this thing into
the desert but first got to get some
coffee
[Applause]
[Music]
time to test out the Osmo pocket this
thing's so cool
the first thing once out is a panel
which is kind of cool because usually
when you're doing a piano you have to
move the camera around but you don't you
just hit the panel button the gimbal
adjusts itself and it moves and gets you
a perfect panel shot also I test out
shooting 60 frames a second so let's see
what that looks like
[Music]
so this will shoot 4k 30 frames and 60
frames a second but I love shooting in
60 frames because it does look really
smooth and then you can slow that down
50 percent and then you can get some
nice slow-mo footage and it'll still be
in 4k I'm into it
are you into a dad I'm very into it it's
really great as the audio is actually
pretty good too and as you can see we
got that Raptor in the background this
thing is so much fun to drive
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm not passing out the 30 frames a
second I'm gonna clean up this little
rock here and then I want to try out the
time-lapse and see what that looks like
okay I flip the camera ready
flip okay I'm trying out the tracking
right now it's kind of cool because
it'll basically I move it tracks my face
yeah so here we are
it's good yeah
so that me yeah perfectly sir this I'm
an confuse it on that one I think you
maybe hit the gimbal limit I might oh no
it still has me oh my now I'm gonna give
you guys an example of the story modes
this is cool because it'll automatically
make you like this short little clip of
a movie it'll show you certain time
length so like 2.5 seconds 3.9 and then
you fill in those little blanks with
some shot it'll automatically cut those
clips into a little movie so let's write
off
[Music]
our little movement you're not so good
I'm saving it
I'm surprised yeah that's good cool
[Music]
I'm extremely impressed with this thing
and I honestly don't we're not really
home without it like the audio was good
the video quality is incredible the fact
that you can track yourself if you get
one of those little log mics that record
SD cards I know Jonathan always uses
those I'm have to ask him if those are
because they're really cool you could
basically be doing like a whole entire
shoot with this setup you also need
another phones that you could film the
other phones but that's a Justine
problem if time-lapse probably should
have done a smaller movement longer time
lapse because this is all we got it's
super short I mean it's it looks cool
there are so many possibilities for this
like I'm extremely excited
[Music]
[Applause]
we're now officially pretty much of the
middle of nowhere we love any reception
you've also got the super 7 for you Mike
I mean this is so much more like I am so
overwhelmed
[Music]
mixed emotions
I'm not gonna try
[Music]
what is the Johnsons Valley desert
Johnson Valley motor Recreation open
areas it's beautiful than getting high
bluffs right now with be mad at pro two
and then i'm going to put up the zoom i
get some cool z we top of the raptor
this has been so fun
[Music]
[Applause]
there's another panel option that I
didn't even see until right now so it'll
take nine different photos so there's
three in the top three in the middle and
three on the bottom
[Applause]
[Music]
I just keep talking about how cool it is
scary on Levi's setup I'm into it
her name is on link for this tripod in
the description below
[Music]
we are off on another hike man I am so
in love with this little ol Osmo like
this thing is it is I keep saying that
it's game-changing what it really is
because you can do anything with just a
phone and this I mean you can do
anything with a phone but this just
gives you this whole added bonus like
I'm moving around and it's still
tracking me are you dizzy
I'm dizzy
[Music]